à Mario Paul l'ultime poche de
résistance soumise à un déluge de feu
dans les entrailles de la gigantesque
cuisine sidérurgica obstale les derniers
soldats Ukrainiens il serait encore 2000
selon les Russes barricadés dans les
sous-sols totalement encerclé sur ces
images filmées par un blogueur
procreamlin on voit ses soldats russes
patrouillés en périphérie de l'usine une
manière de montrer la prise de contrôle
de Mario Paul
dans une savante mise en scène en face
du président Poutine le ministre de la
Défense Sergueï choïcu suggère de donner
la sophinale
inutile tranche le maître du Kremlin
je considère que le projet d'assaut de
la zone industrielle n'a pas de sens il
n'est pas nécessaire de descendre dans
ses catacombes et de ramper sous terre à
travers ses installations industrielles
bloquer cette zone afin que même une
mouche ne passe pas
à l'intérieur de l'usine de nombreux
civils vivent retrancher depuis des
semaines les autorités ukrainiennes
réclament leur évacuation en urgence
nous demandons un cessez le feu pendant
au moins 24 heures pour qu'on puisse
avoir la possibilité d'évacuer les
habitants de Mario Paul qui se cachent
sur le territoire d'azovstacle en
parallèle plusieurs bus de civils ont pu
quitter la ville et sont arrivés à
zaporrija sur ces images fournies par
les séparatistes pro russes un autre
convoi avec à son bord 127 personnes
habitant près de l'usine aurait été
organisée des civils qui auraient pris
la direction de la Russie